but first let's get to Bill milugen he's
live in Mission Texas for us hey Bill
hey Sandra border patrol simply cannot
keep up with the sheer volume of people
crossing our border illegally right now
every day this week they've had more
than 7 000 apprehensions of illegal
immigrants and we want to show you what
these Mass releases look like take a
look at this video out of San Diego
yesterday afternoon what you're looking
at is three unmarked white border patrol
buses they pull up and they start
releasing several hundred illegal
immigrants to City streaks and sidewalks
in San Diego across from a Transit
terminal people work on this bus from as
far away as China and Pakistan and keep
in mind these buses are not from Texas
they're not Greg Abbott's buses these
are the Biden administration's buses
this is border patrol Mass releasing
people you can see handfuls of them are
standing around not knowing where they
are what to do where to go next and
there was a remarkable exchange between
one migrant and a border patrol agent
SES the agent hey am I okay to travel to
Chicago and the agent says yep you're
good to go take a listen
freedom
[Music]
and these Mass releases also taking
place in Border Patrol's Tucson Arizona
sector we shot this video in Sierra
Vista Arizona yesterday afternoon a
Guatemalan family dropped off by border
patrol in a Dollar Tree parking lot just
a random store parking lot they didn't
know where they were they didn't know
what to do and the local sheriff out
there says these Mass Street releases
aren't fair to the community they're not
fair to the migrants take a listen
people come from all over the country to
smuggle here endanger this community the
citizens and we've worked United to
combat that then to find out yesterday
that
CBP is doing Street releases as they
call them safe there's nothing safe
about it
meanwhile here in the state of Texas
Texas is trying to stand its own ground
without the help of the federal
government the video you're looking at
here in El Paso as Texas National Guard
soldiers continue to use razor wire and
physical manpower to try to block large
masses of migrants trying to enter the
United States illegally that group of
migrants waiting in the Rio Grande
expecting to be led into the country but
the state of Texas blocking them that
again happening in El Paso and back out
here live CBP sources tell Fox News that
border numbers for the month of August
are going to be around 230
000 migrant encounters that would be the
highest number or the highest month for
2023 and would come at a time when the
White House is claiming progress and
quote stopping the flow here at our
Southern border that is simply not the
reality on the ground here we'll send it
back to you I appreciate your reporting
from there bill milugen in Mission Texas
for us thank you I'm Steve Ducey I'm
Brian Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley Earhart
and click here to subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis